[Music]
we took note of the recent developments
stressing the strategic importance and
the geopolitical reality of the eu
enlargement process
which represents an investment in peace
in democracy
in prosperity in security and stability
uh in europe the european perspective
for the western balkan countries is
vital for the european union and it is
important not to lose this
momentum second block of discussions
in our council was about the conference
on the future of europe
it is a fundamental element
for the future of europe this conference
and we really want this to be an open
transparent and inclusive process rule
of law is a fundament
of democratic europe and this is why we
at the commission are determined to
uphold and defend
independent judiciary media the general
systems of checks and balances and
support also fight against corruption
today
was mainly for the member states to ask
questions and discuss
about different issues and i want to
thank the ministers for their interest
and engagement